division one of the house finance
committee i find that due to the state
of the emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the coba 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session for pertaining to
division budget matters
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
had the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has
access to contemporary nestle listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal at ledge.state.net
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call
and we will start with a roll call
attendance if you are not
in room 202 with us in the lob please
state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
and where you are which is required
under the right to know law
i am here in room 202 to my left is vice
chairman tracy emmerich
to his left is representative peter
leishman
to my right is representative robert
tuberge
to his right is representative jerry
griffin
representative walls i am present in my
home i'm alone in this part of the house
my
husband and my daughter are elsewhere in
the house
well as it's relevant i heard from
representative hatch earlier he's having
a hard time getting in that's all i
wanted to let you know okay thank you i
was going to say
representative hatch is not yet online
he may dial in
um as well he does he does not have to
be online he can
call in via the phone and maybe he is
doing that
um mr hoffman the first thing i'd like
to have
[Music]
2021-080h
this is replaces house bill
2 sections 69 and 74
and the amendment uh mr hoffman if you
can take us to the right page
and the place is
predominantly date changes this pushes
the family leave plan until the last six
months of the biennium
so mr hoffman please direct us where we
need to be
yes this is uh the same amendment um
with a few changes from the other day
the first change would be on the top of
you'll see starting um in in that
paragraph
on starting on line six you'll see
there's a
a date of march 31st 2022
that was moved ahead by six months
and the same thing on line nine that now
reached january 1st
2023 used to read july 1st 2022
the paragraph at the start of the page
used to
be paragraph three um there was a
paragraph two
that was removed and that had to do with
requiring um
employees to make their premium pay
payments by payroll deduction
thank you okay the family leave bill
this family leave bill makes this
program available to
100 of the adults
in new hampshire and it moves it to the
last six months of the year otherwise
it is the same we have with us the
governor's budget director matt malou
matt do you have anything else you want
to say on this i think we covered it
when you were here before
very well but one last chance the only
thing i think there was one more date
that was in this amendment at the very
end
but i don't know that it needed to
change but i believe there was
just wanted to point that out um i don't
i don't see any date on page 9 either
matt you want uh
mike i don't know which page this would
be on the amendment but there were two
dates that we discussed last time on
when
it needed to take effect and they were
out they were not synchronized
i just wanted to make sure and again
only one of them needed to change which
is probably why we see the amendment the
way it is but just wanted to make sure
that
man i have the old uh the prior
amendment
868 are you do you have that in front of
you
i have the uh hb2 is introduced but i
don't have
the old amendment yeah i had only um
noted the two changes that i described
from the other day
so i think we i think we changed one
matt if i recall
right only one thing only one date
needed to be changed
so i believe we're good but it just
wanted to confirm that
i'm going to leave my amendment with you
and as
mrs lavines told us earlier we can do a
rat
if it comes to that at the end but
you're going to double check that
okay any discussions on the changes to
representative emerick did you have your
microphone on
he's going to do it again because one
cannot hear without mics on
2021-0880h representative eric moves
representative griffin seconds
any discussion on the motion see none if
the clerk could call the role
madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch i believe is having
uh remote control problems
uh representative walsh no okay
the vote is five to one vote is five to
one the amendment passes
then i would like next to turn
to
[Music]
an amendment that represent walls and
mr malou worked on together this is the
20210917h
um
you want to go through section by
section
and i think what we'll do is we'll go
through the whole amendment section by
section
and then have questions so matt if i
could
get you to walk us through this as you
and represent walls worked on this
together
absolutely representative i'll start on
page one line one
deletes section 143 of the bill
this was uh something we've talked about
previously
the language was for the current
biennium and
uh ultimately didn't need to be included
in hb2
i think there's a change on lines six
and seven as well
uh yes so the next part of this
amendment
which deals with section 191 of the bill
simply renames the divisions so that
they are the same
titles everywhere that they appear there
was
a incongruency um in one area
this just brings everything into
alignment
okay
uh lines eleven through sixteen are new
this section is amended i'm not i'm
sorry when i say new i mean amended
different language than what we've seen
yes and this we coordinated with the
department of administrative services to
get the language
exactly the way that they would like to
see it it gives
the new department at the authority
conditional on approval of governor and
council and the director of personnel
ability to move positions equipment or
appropriations
to create the proper expenditure lines
if needed this is something that's been
included in past reorganizations of
state government
it's a catch-all if you will
okay line 21 we've added any public
utility
uh any public utility was existing we've
added or
entities subject to its jurisdiction
given that some
are not classified as public utilities
but do fall under this section
okay well we have a date change on line
yes this brings the language in hb2
into consistency with the appropriations
in hb1
for the full biennium and then starting
at the bottom of page 1
line 29 we're going to have a new
section
that is correct this addresses page two
this addresses that initial period of 60
days
while the commissioner would go through
the governor and council
confirmation process this gives the
governor the authority to designate an
interim commissioner
until gnc has taken action
okay and then on page two line seven we
look at
department of energy unclassified
positions established
the change here is the director of
offshore wind
has been removed from this list which
would be a classified role as opposed to
an unclassified
position okay we go to line 28
this is a correcting
the reference uh currently in hb2
was directed to the commission but this
authority would exist with department of
energy okay
and down to line 36 line 36
this replaces section 227 which deals
with the site evaluation committee
the membership of which no longer has
any changes whatsoever
the only change we're making is the
administrative attachment
to the department of energy okay
page three line twelve page three
line twelve again this corrects the
references
from commission to the department of
energy
and down to page three uh line 35
we immense we deleted a section yes
this authority would stay with the
public utilities commission so there is
no
could we go through all of this and then
hold your questions
and then we'll i will back up as far as
you want to back up
if you don't mind just so we get through
the changes
line two page four this clarifies that
this authority
is shared between the commission and the
department
uh and that's the change that you see on
line three
all right and then line ten line
10 this section is clarifying
again shared authority between the
commission
and the department of energy we go to
the bottom of page four we have line 35
and 36
this change is in line 35 and 36
it clarifies that the commission has the
obligation to disallow payment if
recommended by the department
just clarifying who has that authority
okay we're going to turn to page five
and we're on the end of line six and
just line
seven this corrects the
uh legal action the department would not
issue orders they would issue rules
the first version corrected the
reference but didn't correct the type of
action that they would take okay line 10
this changes commission to department in
each instance
line 20 the only change is the very last
line 33 changing commission to the
department where these entities should
register with
okay so we're going to turn to page six
line 11 which is going to
line 11 is alliance 23
to 28 it removes the instances where
approval of the general court would not
be required to increase the system's
benefits charge
why did you remove that so the general
court
and the fiscal committee would need to
approve all changes in any instance
that removes this exception that was
carved in
to restore the full authority of the
okay we're going to turn we're not going
to debate we're going to go through all
the changes we'll go back
this clarifies which and which regional
entities
each the both the department
and the commission have authority to
engage with um these were co-mingled
we've separated those out based on where
all right we're going to turn to page
eight and we go to
line 19 which is going to amend a
section following
this this section
puts everything back to current law the
initial proposal could have been
construed
to force an ongoing proceeding to
restart
our intention is not to force a process
to start from scratch
so we've removed any change directing
the department of energy to
create a new process but continue to use
the existing one
okay line 33 addresses the section
following
this is a new section that was not in
house bill 2
but the only change here is changing
references
from the commission to the department of
energy
all right and to representative
leishman's concerns last time we spoke
department is a defined term that's des
we've specifically spelled out
environmental services each time it
should appear
all right the last change we have before
we open the floor to questions is
page 10 the effective date was changed
to july 1st 2021 correct
that's correct and that's consistent
with the appropriations in hb1
all right representative lischmann you
had the first question so i want to go
back to you go back to wherever you'd
like to be sir
so you're looking at hb2
21 membership and i think
i have a note here that you raised a
question
yeah well now they want to go back to
nine and they're giving up
g madam chair we're having
trouble hearing representative leishman
oh well we have a microphone little
issue i think we just solved with a once
button
perhaps all right
those pesky on buttons what can i say
good morning mr hatch
good morning madam chair my apologies my
computer my wi-fi
okay so peter on line 36 what they
are agreeing to do is leaving it at nine
members um
the osi is i understand this osi didn't
really have
a seat before and so you've agreed this
we don't need this is that correct matt
that's correct okay i just wanted to
make sure it was clear thank you
that's all i have okay matt i'd like to
go to
and can we talk a little bit more about
this strikeout what we've
what you're proposing to strike out is
the requirement of prior approval
of the new hampshire general court shall
somebody needs to approve that it does
not say fiscal can
if you've put that out so there's
quite a bit of history here the
intention
is to return the authority the general
court to approve
all increases in the system's benefits
charge
but where is that written in here that
what we've removed are these certain
instances where the general court did
not need to be consulted
okay now we see that when we went
through
and you did exactly what i did you asked
to you concentrated on the changes so i
appreciate that thank you
here i assume that since your name is on
this you're completely in favor of the
changes
my name is on this because
representative walls
and matt malou were working on it and
the chair gets
the is the target for the person who's
going to have their name on it
i really had they worked independently
without me
i had nothing to do with this i didn't
see it until you guys got it either
so it is what it is
madam chair yes you represent walls
i didn't see your hand raised is did you
raise your hand
i didn't i'm sorry okay all right i just
wanted to know if i was overlooking you
i apologize if i was
let's just plan to enter the
conversation i just want to say this is
there's a lot of changes in here that go
beyond what i talked about with matt i
don't
object to them but i just wanna
understanding that
some of the changes i proposed are in
here a lot of the changes were not
necessarily my proposal and honestly the
first time i have seen this amendment is
right now
so i think i said you and matt worked on
it together
and then peter asked why my name was on
it and i said because somebody had to be
the target
so even though i left you guys working
on it when we left last i was fine with
that
and matt was already doing work on it
you wanted to work with him so
i'm perfectly happy with that in fact my
name ended up on it not a problem
that's fine i just didn't want to be
claiming an amendment that
literally i hadn't seen and i didn't
have input on a lot of the changes
okay
any other discussion representation
uh thanks venom chair as the cheer knows
i've been
torn one way or the other to go with
this and
uh i did receive an email
um from the past chair
bob backus of the science and technology
committee which
leads me to a question for matt
okay
uh let's get some background
i think if you mute yourself in the
interim and turn off
do you have on your do you have your
phone as well as your computer
yeah my computer i can't see anything
never mind
that's okay what you need to do bill
is move your speaker your sound
to zero and use the phone you'll be fine
so man i guess the question i have for
you bob mentioned that
you had actually made the motion during
this commission study
to create the department of energy that
you suggested the matter needed further
study so
what brought you around from your motion
to further study this to now completely
support it
i i think ultimately this issue
that was before the study commission was
looking at
a broader scope right there was
consideration to bring components from
the department of environmental services
in as well and groups like department of
natural and cultural resources were part
of those conversations it was really a
broad scope of that study
broader than what we've put forward so
now that we've been able to
look at the good work that commission
did and identify
some of these areas for collaboration uh
when i was with the office of strategic
initiatives this is a proposal we could
have supported
had the committee or have the study
commission gone in that direction
but again there there seemed to be a
much wider scope
and a broader reorganization than what
we
see no additional discussion i think
is your mic on i guess i didn't move it
yet
second representative emerick moves the
adoption of two zero two one zero nine
one seven eight
representative griffin seconds it
see no discussion on the motion if the
clerk could call the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
it appears he's trying to vote no he's
gone
okay
i didn't get uh representative hatch
disconnected
uh the vote is six to nothing with
representative hatch disconnected from
yes
matt i got from lba
a slug of amendments
some from you some from representative
walls which she emailed to me kind of
late yesterday
or i got him late yesterday when i was
in my mail
so i'm going to pass out the hb1
mr hoffman this is on governor's budget
page three
five nine three six zero if people have
their budget at home
pages three five nine three six zero
matt is offering an amendment that he's
going to walk
this is not up yet wait a minute mr hub
it's a slow process matt you got all the
and here it comes thank you mike okay
matt
it's up excellent this
is a technical correction when we were
moving this one individual position it's
position number 14373
it was only moved in one
year of the biennium so it would have
moved within the department
in year two that's not the intention
this
increase here is directly
offset by the decrease
in accounting unit 1889. so this is a
technical correction
on the movement of position one four
three seven
three to a you one
eight eight seven and you won it for
both years and it was one year
that's correct so it again we're just
moving where it's budgeted but the
total amount budgeted does not change
any questions for the governor's budget
director on this
errata change representative walls
what is the position it's a number but
i'm sure it has a title beyond that
this position deals with wholesale
electricity issues
uh it's a direct report to another
position
that position properly existed in the
same spot both years
and this again just brings it into
conformity within the division of policy
and programs
thank you i would move this amendment
uh for the department of energy
representative emerick moves
the hb1 errata amendment representative
griffin seconds
discussion when you're ready sir clerk
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative lischmann yes represent
the hatch
yes represent walls yes total seven
nothing unanimous
okay
uh all right i have
mr hoffman i am looking at amendment hb
1a
the number is 20210827h
and matt this is the abolishment of
positions
madam chair uh yes i'm sorry to
interrupt um
the previous amendment was a page one of
four oh we have to do all of them um
okay so matt do you have
mr hoffman i guess we'll look at page
two before we look at the amendment i
just called out
i i think i'm sharing that
but i can't i think you are
this amendment is the other half of the
technical correction
which you see in fy 23 there's a
decrease
the other thing that is happening
simultaneously
is funding position 14358
100 utility assessment funds this
request came at
the representative walls
as well as others to refund this
position which deals with regulatory
innovation
and strategy representative walls this
is one of the positions that that you
had mentioned
represented walls would you like to
comment i just want to understand which
position
in this form it's hard for me to tell
position number 14358
which was the regulatory innovation and
strategy
do you have a comment represent walls
you'd like you want to make
i do not at this point there were well
okay except i will say generally there
were a number of positions that were put
in the department of energy
that were really puc functions and i
tried to move them back
i misunderstood and thought that none of
them were going to get moved back
so i'm pleasantly surprised to see this
so let me just clarify representative
this position
was unfunded we're now refunding it
but it is in the department of energy
not the puc this is separate from those
other positions that you had requested
okay representative leishman moves the
adoption of
the governor's budget page 362 hb1
amendment representative emmerich
seconds
seeing no additional discussion mr clerk
if you can call the roll force again
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman representative
hatch
yes represent waltz yes unanimous seven
nothing madam german
okay so mike having made that mistake
once let's turn to page three if you can
go down a page we'll continue
now that you got us back on the right
path and this is another technical
correction
move position number nw065
to accounting unit 1891
from accounting unit 1891 to 1888
and position 18945
from accounting unit 1888 to 1891. it
looks like we're swapping positions in
two places matt you're on
that's correct uh nw065
is an i.t position that is best
situated in accounting unit 1888
which i believe is the support division
but i can grab that page of the budget
um conversely position
18945 is moving in the opposite
direction
which is why the number the overall
for the it position it made sense based
on
the functions of the division that it
and position eighteen
um i i'd have to look and see exactly
which
position this one is i don't have my
full note on that
okay
see no discussion representative emerick
moves
the adoption of the governor's budget
page
359 360 technical correction to these
two positions on page three
i don't see any discussion so you're on
again sir clerk
okay thank you madam chairman yes vice
chairman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative walls
yes does that have been nothing you know
okay
and that brings us to page four
which mr hoffman will bring up on the
screen
and this is the corollary to those two
movements isn't it matt the i.t
position and the other one that is
correct although i believe
class 60 should be a
as opposed to a positive mine says
negative
oh well okay then then yes we were all
set then
yes i must have a slightly older version
but the numbers on the screen are
correct yes that
okay numbers on the screen are correct
numbers those are the numbers i got this
morning for mr hoffman so we're in good
shape
representative emerick moves the
adoption representative griffin seconds
uh madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
the clerk folks yes
representative griffin yeah fair
president leashman yeah representative
hatch
yes representative walsh yes seven
nothing unanimous unanimously
okay now i think we're done with that
one
and now we're going to look at some
abolished positions
so this is amendment 2 0
2 1 0 8
and when mr hoffman brings it up we'll
excuse madam chairman could you is that
zero
eight two seven h looks like this i just
is that visible now it is thank you
okay man you're on the change here is in
line
eight these are two vacant positions
that do not need to exist after this
reorganization
so uh they're one of them is an
administrative secretary that's
duplicative
under the new structure um that comes
from osi the other one is one
at the puc um
is a similar situation to vacant
position that doesn't need to exist
in the new structure this helps address
some of those double budgeting concerns
that the committee had raised
during our first presentation questions
i'm just curious about how a department
of health and human services
position ended up in the same amendment
that's existing
in the same exception of hb2 so this is
everything that's in section 7
of hb from hp1 so there's no changes to
hhs
that's in hp2s it is okay the
mr hoffman is there any chance that
division three
is doing anything with that hhs person
um there is a chance
but we look at all of these house bill 1
sections together
at the end of the process to make sure
that we don't
step on each other's toes so to speak
okay if you could uh just make mr ripple
aware this that we're doing only the
energy ones
and the hhs one is whatever he wants to
do
yes okay represent walsh you have your
hand up
i do thank you um i just want to check
with matt and make sure that
before i vote yes on this that none of
these the things i'm trying to restore i
don't want to contradict myself and i
just can't tell from looking at these
numbers
not the two in 2021 the second part of
this amendment madam chair if you'd like
to go through that as well
is an additional abolish position 9u573
this is an unclassified position
that would become a classified role in
the new structure
given that there's now a unclassified
division director
for the enforcement division it doesn't
make sense to have a second unclassified
position
the duties of this job are maintained
but in a classified role so if i may
follow up madam chair yes please do
so i don't understand when this is is
this the director of safety and security
that is correct um and i know
representative walls here have a
proposal to break this off into its own
division
which would preserve an unclassified
director over
it either if the if the committee was to
vote in favor of that
it would make sense to have an
unclassified director over that division
but it does not in our opinion make
sense to have
an unclassified um that's
it doesn't it it's essentially it's a
role that could become classified into
the new structure
well given that it's undercutting one of
the amendments i'm about to present
i'm not going to support this then i
would i have no problem with the first
half but i'm not going to undercut
myself
okay representative emerick
moves the adoption of this amendment
representative griffin seconds
when you're ready you may call the role
sir clerk
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
clerk votes yes representative griffin
representative lischmann
yes represent them hatch no represent
walls
no uh five to nothing five to two
all right a little another stack of
matt you must have been busy over the
weekend because mike hoffman brought up
a wheelbarrow full of paper this morning
those
all right mr hoffman we're looking at
administrative support governor's page
361 hb1 amendment and it's about
uh transfers to doit i think this is
trying to get
all of the it money into one place but
or he can ask you to talk about if he's
uh mike is this one of the amendments
that that we brought forward i believe
we've addressed all of the governor's
office requested amendments
this was a suggestion to consolidate all
of the class 27
and it's a seven page
amendment which just shows the class 27
amounts being reduced in
other accounting units and
combined into 1891 administrative
support
this this is assuming all seven pages
are just
offsetting what we see here uh this
probably is an outgrowth of the
conversations we've had with doit
that we do that the money is correct
but there may be better ways to cost
allocated across funding streams
i don't have any opposition to this
reorganization of where class 27s exist
but there may be additional action in
the senate
to put money at the puc specifically
but to the extent that we're just
reorganizing class lines there's
authority in hb2 as well
for das to work with the department to
address this as well
as long as we're addressing the right
amount of
money it shouldn't be an
issue because the department can also
per state law come to fiscal committee
request the establishment of a line item
and the transfer of the funds so there
are
multiple ways to make sure the money
gets in the right place especially with
the new department
yes mr hoffman can we vote all these
with one motion yes there are they're
all part of one action
the very last page is the
doit adjustment that
we we worked with the department of
information technology to make sure that
we're putting the correct amount
in that it for energy account
okay thank you so
one motion would adopt the doit
reorganization of the money so moved
second representative griffin seconds
representative emerick moves
the adoption of reorganization of the
doit money
sir clerk when you're ready madam
chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk beauties
representative griffin yes
representative leishman representative
hatch
yes representative yes unanimous seven
nothing madam chairman
okay
matt
no i don't think this is yours this is
mine
but you're off the hook matt
uh mike would you bring up the
unfunding of the vacant unclassified
administrator position
this position is currently vacant
and this unfunds it but does not abolish
it
for the coming year it's been vacant for
quite a while they're not even reaching
out to higher and now we're reorganizing
the entire situation over there
so it gives us a
cut of about 250 000
in the budget representative emerick
moves to approve
when you're ready okay madam chairman
yes
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin
yes reverend leashman representative
hatch
yes representative walls yes unanimous
matt these next are not yours but i am
going to bring forward
um the amendments that represent walls
had prepared i will
after i get them up on the screen i will
have her speak to each one
and i'm going to start mike with the
mercury analyzer
position or equipment
mary beth when it comes up on the screen
yeah there we go if you'd like to walk
us through your amendment
i'd be happy to so there's sort of a sad
story that goes with this and that is
last thur susan carlson who's the ceo of
the department of environmental services
is one of my neighbors and has been for
over 20 years we've known each other a
long time
and we have a tight neighborhood and
last thursday morning i got a call that
her husband had died that morning
so i immediately picked up the phone
called her and said sue what can i do
and she we talked for a couple minutes
about peter and then she immediately
turned the conversation to this and she
said there's
one thing i desperately need i need this
mercury analyzer
and i said how much and she told me
about 55 000 i'm like
we can do that i will try that so that
is the story behind this amendment
um is that literally her husband wasn't
cold yet and she's begging me for a
mercury analyzer
and i thought this is pretty serious if
that's the one thing she can think of
in the midst of this pretty overwhelming
grief so
i brought the amendment in that this is
one thing that apparently the department
really needs it's a relatively small
amount of money
i'm sure the money is there somewhere
and so i brought the amendment
well while i appreciate that i find it
very strange that neither the
commissioner
nor miss carlson approached the chair of
the committee with this need
so well i think miss carlson you should
know her husband's been in the icu for
six weeks before he passed
away i know that i subsequently have
seen her this weekend and she was
talking about just getting caught up she
hadn't realized we'd cut the 11 million
from des
i think she has perhaps not been is on
top of things in the last six weeks that
she ordinarily would be given her
personal situation so
i'm not sure she or the commissioner
were fully aware of this until she
brought it up with me
the committee you're saying your
contention is the commissioner doesn't
know what's in his budget because this
mercury
analyzer is not something we cut
i'm not sure that i would put it that
way but apparently
i'm not sure why you didn't hear from
the commissioner i can only speculate as
to why you didn't hear from
ms carlson matt do you have a comment
the only thing that i would add and the
comment at the bottom is correct this
was
included in the governor's march third
letter of areas we
but not included in his budget that's
correct but
yes not included in his budget
question ma'am chair representation does
anyone know what this person or this
position does
i'll analyze mercury or no i believe
this is a piece of equipment not a
person this is this is literally a piece
of equipment that they use
a piece of equipment i'm kind of
surprised
i think maybe the reason we didn't hear
from commissioner scott is we
he might have some federal funds to
replace this rather than general funds
because it seems like something that
commissioner scott would have been on
top of and i know
um he's not contacting me at all
my understanding madam chairs they need
general funds for this but
okay well i'm going to move to itl this
because we have not heard from the
commissioner
and it was not in the original
governor's budget
madam chair i'd like to point out though
that the governor did ask for it in his
subsequent letters so clearly the
governor
and the commissioner are aware of the
need for it i can't imagine the governor
would have put it in his letter without
the commissioner
we cannot discuss without a second when
you haven't given me a chance to see if
there's a second on the motion represent
walls
sorry thank you representative leishman
representative leishman
seconds for discussion i proposed to itl
this
because it was not in the governor's
budget
the commissioner has not contacted me i
don't believe he's contacted the vice
chairman either as he would have sent
that on to me
and while the governor has put this in a
letter the governor was not proposing
any cuts to do that
the cut we had to make in des i work
very hard to get
an a
corresponding section into hb2
that should we have revenues that go up
given the pandemic
we would be able to fund all those
wastewater treatment programs because
that's something i've been
very fond of funding but i think that's
got to be my top priority and that's
where we had to
leave this given the ways and means
revenues in the house
and that's why i voted to itl this
motion i do think that the commissioner
who has contacted me many times about
many things could have reached out
representative leishman thanks manager
i'll be supporting the motion because i
think
it's a little vague and coming at the
last minute and i
certainly like to get all the facts
before i would support something so i'll
oh i feel very sorry for susan carlson i
do too
i think we'll have to send i'll get her
see no additional discussion on the
motion to itl
this amendment if the clerk could call
the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative lischmann yes
representative hatch
yes representative walsh no
voters six to one vote is six to one
um this next amendment
is about department of energy
administrative support
it is a representative walls amendment
it is
multiple pages so let me pass it out
let me have mr hoffman bring it up
online
and represent walls if you could work us
through page
one first and then we will look at page
two
so these are positions that really have
puc functions and so the intent
is to have the puc position stay with
the puc and not move to the department
of energy
that's that applies to every single
thing that's set forth here
um so their administrators are so how
many positions are you talking
uh by class i would have to rely on mr
hoffman to help me with that but the
bottom if you look at the note at the
bottom it says it's a general counsel
it's a clerk it's an administrator two
hearing examiners
and a senior hearing examiner so those
are the positions all their i
confess i cannot always align them with
the class but that
is the note at the bottom summarizes the
positions i'm trying to move
class 10 permanent classified
and class 12 personal services
unclassified and you're moving
benefits is that correct
yeah to follow the positions that is
correct matt would did you discuss this
at some point with has this been a
discussion
we did discuss this both with
representative walls
and also our office given that the
department of energy
has expressed authori has the express
duty and obligation in hb2 to provide
any necessary support to the puc as an
administratively attached agency
we don't see the need to move these
positions
um and we we we've come to the decision
that
we'd prefer the current structure so
you're not in favor is that you're not
in favor of this amendment you prefer it
as it is
was that the bottom line all right
representative lischmann all a question
man
shared to representative walls i'm
just curious the advantage as you heard
matt say administratively attached that
was going to be my question to you
if they're administratively attached the
puc to the department of energy
what would be the advantage of what
you're proposing
well because the function actually is
like one of these is like for hearings
the hearings actually occur in the puc
the biggest one honestly is the general
counsel is the puc is an adjudicatory
body and
this reform has stripped it of its
lawyers
and there's talk of using the lawyers
from the department of justice the fact
of the matter is the department of
justice doesn't have anybody
currently trained in public utility law
which is a
highly specialized area of law when
they've used them in the past they've
had problems with not getting adequate
uh services out of them where they've
literally had to rewrite things that
came out of doj
so the idea is to have them have their
own general counsel
perhaps even a stack and lawyer with
them but at least their own general
counsel who understands public utility
law
and can help these non-lawyer
adjudicators come up with an appropriate
uh decision in their hearings
i there is not a public utility
commission in the country i believe that
doesn't have their own general counsel
it just seems like by stripping the
general counsel's office and these
these other positions are more support
positions but by stripping this out
it's a bridge too far it's just taken so
much out that it eviscerates the public
utility commission
and i think it's in the interest of
everyone both us
and the the utilities to have a a
well-functioning public utility
commission
and i think as proposed this does not
happen
representative policeman a question for
either matt or the chair of
representative walls
i do recall there were several attorneys
left with the department of energy do
you know how many
our intention was to leave all of the
attorneys
at the department of energy the reason
being
a is that those are existing
hierarchical relationships right the puc
as it currently exists as a legal
division
so we kept all of those direct reports
together in the support division
the support division again has the
express duty to support both the
department
and the commission those lawyers would
support
both the state's regulatory efforts from
the department to build the record
while also other attorneys and we didn't
prescribe
how many or which individuals would
support the commission
to do their work and just as a separate
point of information i believe the puc
expressly pays for two attorneys
that do puc issues a hundred percent of
the time at doj
um i do believe that one of the things
that's happened is the general counsel's
position at the puc is being abolished
and i believe that
person does not transfer over to the
department of energy if i read this
correctly
that is correct that position is
abolished at the end of its current
term it would continue to exist until
that term expires so not abolished at
the beginning of the biennium but
whenever the position was
due to expire anyway that's correct
so that the term ends at some point in
fiscal 23
so the position is abolished at the end
of fiscal 23.
matt have we passed a a separate
amendment
abolishing that or does that already
exist that was in hb2 is introduced
representative madam chair i would move
itl i think we have to let the governor
organize the way he wants to organize
and not second-guess it
i would agree with that in a second
representative
emmerich moves itl representative
griffin seconds
um the discussion was from
representative emerick that he thinks
the governor needs to organize and they
need to see how this works
before we make additional changes
additional
madam chair yes representative hatch
thank you madam chair just i know what
was stated but
i just for my own clarity could
marry gus please again iterate the
potential consequences
to the department of energy with the
elimination of this
um position
this amendment does not eliminate any
positions mr hatch
this alignment uh amendment transfers
positions
and it would refund the general counsel
position
that that nine you position is currently
abolished
at the end of the biennium yeah this
wouldn't restore it
so ergo the concern for the change i
guess is what i'm looking for
to be made clear
if may i if i may address it yes you may
um it's it really comes down to how well
it functions how well the public utility
commission functions
if their staff is in the department of
energy and not answerable to the
commission
and if they no longer have a general
counsel uh the belief is is that they're
just going to be not particularly
functional
and you know the the utilities this
is i feel a little bizarre doing this
because in many ways this is a position
that supports
private industry this supports the
utilities who want
a fully functional puc because they rely
on it they're regulating industries most
of them
they cannot increase their rates they
cannot perform a lot of their basic
functions without the
without a functioning puc and so this
allows
the smooth functioning of the puc and
and allows the staff to stay where it
actually
does its work and it just seems to me to
be a logical flow of having the staff
that does the work for the puc
in the puc representation
so madam chair i'm going to rely heavily
on again
reaching out to some legislative
colleagues
that looked at this last year and one of
the things that struck me and i
underlined
from uh former chairman backus isn't he
also an attorney
yes bob because he was cheering science
and tech last biennium okay
and he says here but in my view a
serious reworking of the puc is long
overdue
so with that i will support the motion
of itm
that's basically what i had gotten when
i reached out to find out about the work
of that
group last year as well was that there
was feeling that the puc needs some
reorganization and
maybe a fresh way of looking at things
to go forward
madam chair if i may address
representative leishman's observation
i too got that email from representative
backus and i don't necessarily disagree
with it
i just think again that this is a bridge
too far there is
already a major reorganization of the
puc happening
but deleting these positions is going to
limit its functionality and they're two
different things what
representative backus is concerned about
is moving a lot of the policy positions
the department of energy
my amendment does not undo that the
policy positions that he felt were an
impediment to
shall we say progress in the energy
field continue to be with the department
of energy
this is an administrative thing that
just is really more administrative
functions this is not
the policy changes he was concerned
about
okay we have a motion on the floor we've
been discussing it the motion
is itl on this amendment we've had
ample discussion with the clerk call the
rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
the clerk for ts representative griffin
yes representative lischmann yes
representative hatch no representative
walls
no the vote is five to two
the amendment is itl now that
was pages i think one and two however
there was a separate if you
um mr hoffman if you can bring up the
budget
footnote which we have not discussed nor
have we voted on
representative wallace this is your
proposal please speak
um yes it was um the idea being that
there were two attorneys that were
coming out of this reorganization at doj
that were going to be assigned to the
department of energy and again in an
attempt to provide
adequate legal support to the public
utility commission the idea was to have
one assigned to the department of energy
commission
additional discussion
seeing none if the clerk could call the
role madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes yes president
griffin yes representative
okay i have another representative
hb220210943h
okay represent walls i would like you to
go through this section by section
please
dan let me pull it up the way you've got
it um
yep i got the same thing on my screen um
so there is a division in the public
utility commission
that's a division of security and safety
and it turns out that the
head of that division has become a
nationally
known expert and he
is the reason that we did not have
uh the gas explosions in people's homes
like they had in massachusetts with
columbia gas
because he held the gas companies here
in new hampshire to a higher standard
that made sure that there was enough
safety that we didn't have those kinds
of issues
um he is so much the national expert
that last month when the texas
electrical system failed for failure to
winterize he is the person they turned
to nationally and said how do we fix
this
um and it is a function that i think
really should stay in the public utility
commission given the nature of the
function
and at relating directly to uh utilities
it's safety and security
for utilities and uh
the idea is and and this came up in the
amendment i voted
against earlier that this would be a
another division head
it would be a gnc approved position and
it would allow him
and his staff to uh
be moved or remain in the puc where they
would do their work
ensuring the safety and security of all
of our utilities in the state
and my concern is is that if we put him
in
energy under the division of enforcement
we're going to lose him
and i think he's an incredibly valuable
asset i think his
job warrants being at the division level
um
with a gnc approval and so that's why i
put this amendment in
to try and take that division and put it
back in the puc where i think it can be
most effective and he can be most
effective
or his successor okay but you were asked
to go through the amendment line by line
so could you please start
with line section two lines three
through six
and walk us through the amendment and
tell us what is going on in each section
okay so number two says that the natural
gas companies report
to um
well it's pretty self-explanatory they
report to the uh
department the president center and the
speaker of the house and the uniform
matter
for lost and and gas each year that's
part of the safety we're talking about
really
and so that's the energy department
in that that part yes
um but then it goes on and it says
transfer powers and functions
um
you know i honestly did not read this as
closely as i should have
um i know what i asked for and what i
explained to you is what i asked for but
you're right it appears that
the beginning part of this relates to
the department of energy the second part
then starting on section 205
relates to the puc and if you get down
with the puck
but what about lines 10 through 13
um you've jumped ahead to line 27
i have and you're right it says that
this stuff stays in the department of
energy
um as of september 1st 2021
so um it is the personnel
it is some of the regulatory stuff stays
in the department of energy
some of it then goes down to the
pipeline program to the puc
and madam chair i did not look at this
line by line i looked at this as an
overall
knowing what i asked for in an amendment
madam chair i cannot i can offer
um some help with the technical changes
the or the detailed changes because i
worked on this for representative waltz
if that would be helpful mr hoffman
on the top of the first page that
paragraph
adds the gas pipeline safety program
to the list of
those receiving the report
on line 10 there's an exception
to this rsa 363 22a
which is for the gas
then this reporting here
was is assigned to the gas pipeline
safety program on line 18.
and also it describes
who the report is sent to how much of
this is in existing law because nothing
most of this with the exception of a new
section below is existing law that's
being
changed to retain the separate
um to retain the program as a separate
unit or make the program a separate unit
which would be under the puc as opposed
to the energy department
representation do you have a question
you're looking as perplexed as i am
yes man of chair thanks um i'm still
having a hard time getting my head
around this
if they're administratively attached the
puc
why wouldn't this function have even
more strength
under the department of energy versus
just a sub
category of the like the puc i
it's all one functioning new
department it's kind of like the water
resources board
is kind of administratively attached to
des i don't know i'm
i'm troubled i guess represent griffin
it seems to me that the governor has
presented a plan
for the department of energy and we
ought to let that plan go forward and
madam chair if i may address
representation somebody is speaking at
the moment representative laws your hand
is not up
representative griffin contin i mean
representative griffin
were you done well i'd like to make a
motion to itless
all right representative griffin is
moving to itl
representative emmerich is seconding
uh discussion of the motion represent
walls
thank you manager so i thought the
representative was done speaking i was
not trying to interrupt anyone
um i i did this solely because i want to
make sure that this position
has the strength and the authority to do
the enforcement that it needs to be done
and that it it is an independent
division and
while i admittedly am not as intimately
familiar with the details as expressed
in here
i do understand the concept and i think
the concept
is one that will provide the greatest
protection for the residents of this
see no further discussion on the motion
to itl
house bill two amendment two zero two
one o nine
four three h will the clerk please call
the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes uh
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
representative pulse no vote is five to
two
motion passes five to two there is
attached to this
a second amendment which
i don't think can go into effect without
the first amendment but we probably need
to vote on it
because this is the hb1 amendment
that moved
approximately 1.6 million dollars
around in the department of energy over
the biennium
representative griffin has moved to itl
representative hamrick has seconded
discussion on the hb1 amendment to move
1.6 million dollars
in within the department of energy
representative
thanks madam chair i just and i know
it's been said and i
just like it you said one more time i
think the governor's budget director has
made it pretty clear at least to me
that whether it be the gas line safety
program or whatever
it will still have the same strength to
even be enhanced
with the department of energy is that
that is our intent and again given that
it's an administratively attached agency
to the extent that any interplay needs
to
occur the department's required to
provide that to the commission
thanks man any other discussion
see none the clerk could call the role
on the itl
uh madam chairman yes the vice chairman
yes the clerk wrote yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
no representative walls no the vote is
five to two
i have no more energy
amendments we have
reached a point where we have no more
energy amendments
uh matt and mary beth is that true have
i voted
all the amendments the two of you
presented matt i believe you voted
everything
the only thing i would want to just
check on would be the names of some of
the accounting units in hb1
we're not going to change those at this
late date i saw that take that to the
senate
where they have more time because we're
at the end of that map i appreciate that
thank you
representative wallace did we vote on
all your amendments you did madam chair
thank you for bringing them all up
um the last amendment the last vote we
have to take on the department of energy
is the approval of the department of
energy's budget as amended in
hb1 representative emerick
moves the approval as amended
representative griffin seconds
and
we know whose turn it is now sir clerk
okay
thank you madam chairman votes yes vice
chairman yes
uh clerk vote yes representative griffin
yes representative leachman
yes representative hatch hello
representative walsh
no motion passes five to two i didn't
hear that okay
i wish i could say we were completely
done
matt i think we're done with you you are
welcome to stay
as always we enjoy having you here
it's been great to be the honorary
eighth member of division one the past
few weeks
mr hoffman if you could bring up the
representative
major amendment 20210912h
which addresses sections 102 and 105
and let me see if i can find those
sections for you
we are looking at page 46
okay sections 102
address the business profits tax
credit carry forward limited payments
due with returns
and estimates which is found in rsa 77-a
colon 7. and what
this amendment does
which was given to me by representative
major
is it replaces all of those
and what i can tell you about this
amendment
and i may have we'll go through some of
the
new credits but this amendment was
presented to ways and means
early last week they worked on it
together as a committee
and by thursday although i'm not
positive which day they voted it in
ways and means unanimously voted
to send this to us to include to replace
these three sections in hb2
and you can see that if you look lines
9 through 17 starting on line 9
the taxable periods ending honorably
after
december 31st 2022
a credit shall be allowed in an amount
up to 500 percent of the total tax
liability for the taxable period
and the remainder of the over payment
shall be refunded and then line
12 for taxable periods ending honor
after december 31st 2025
a credit shall only be allowed in an
amount amount
up to 250 of the total tax liability
for the taxable period and the remainder
of the overpayment
shall be refunded and then finally
lines 15 through 17
for taxable periods ending on or after
december 31st 2027 a credit shall be
only allowed in the amount of up to a
hundred percent of the total tax
liability
for the taxable period and the remainder
of the overpayment shall be a fund
refunded you then go down to
line 25
and it is repeating those three lines
that i read through page two section
three
so what they have done is they have
changed the amount
that a business may do this
representative major said their
committee
was unanimously in favor we've been
asked to put this into hb
2 and representative emerick
is going to move to adopt representative
griffin is going to second that motion
and if you have any questions i think
poor mr hoffman is going to try to
answer them because
this is i told you what i know
representative leishman
thanks a question for representative
hatch who served on
ways and means does this all look good
to you or
um honestly i'm not sure yet if if mr
hoffman could um
give some indication um i know there
hasn't been a fiscal note or has there
i'm just um i think i understand it and
then
i think it looks good but i'd like to
hear from mr hoffman first if i could
please
madam chair yes if this is nancy lavines
please if mike wants to answer that but
there might be someone from the
department of revenue
who is um on this soon if they are maybe
they can answer
i can't see anyone because i'm sharing
my scream
i don't know if mr hoffman can mike can
see anybody
i thought we had a few amendments so i
left my screen at home
tired of carting it around well i
i don't see anyone from the department
of revenue
right off the bat but if you are from
the department and able to answer this
i can i can try to reach someone perhaps
to answer this question
representative leishman said that's all
right representative walsh your hand is
up
it is thank you man i'm sure so what
this is clearly is this is a step down
on the credit
my q question is are there any limits on
it now
or is it just an unlimited credit that's
allowed
i understood from representative major
it was unlimited now and that
representative almighty had some concern
about that
worked with representative major on this
when this came up in the
hb2 and that's why they passed this
unanimously but i did
i knew they were working on it we were
up here and then i just
the although i was home on thursday i
didn't listen in on their meeting
representative griffin
i don't know i i kind of like to know
why they're limiting it
uh it's a liability that should be on
our books and dra told them they
couldn't figure out how to put it on our
books i know that because representative
walsh
might have heard that but representative
major
told me that when i said why this change
and he said because
and so i've said okay thanks for the
amendment then he handed me the
amendment on friday
madam chair yes if i may just add to
this and i
and like i said i think it looks okay
that that's been a
great concern for a number of years is
we have a
uh unknown unquantified
liability to the state out there that
could be magnanimous
would be the only word i can think of
and
the only question i have is is enough
ways and means was unanimous
and i that just connected with me my
apologies
i think this is fine i wasn't sure of
the uh 500 or the 100
it's it's much better than what exists
today and if that was a compromise
between um within ways and means
i suppose i i don't have any place in
questioning that so i guess
thinking this through a little bit
longer i would support this
amendment thank you mr hatch without
added
okay we do have a motion on the floor of
ought to pass
and when we pass this we have
effectively
accepted sections 102
through 105 as
amended in house bill 2. so on the
motion about to pass
mr clerk could you call the roll madam
chairman
yes vice chairman yes representative of
the clerk for otis representative
griffin yes
representative leishman represent hatch
yes
represent walls yes uh unanimous seven
nothing
okay the motion passes seven to nothing
let me
mark those sections off on my
to-do list here because we still have a
yeah i know well i'm afraid what we're
going to do
is
if you're here represent taberge
brought us all the best tasting homemade
cranberry bread
he went out and picked wild cranberries
he cooks and he needs to share his food
with us so we got
a jar of jelly one day that's to die for
i had on my english muffins this weekend
and we had this bread which i ate when i
got here because like representative
leishman i was early this morning
so it was terrific but we are going to
break for an
hour for lunch we have a few more
amendments and a few more things to do
and we'll be back at one o'clock mr
hoffman or
mrs lavinas can one of you put up a
recess until lunch and everybody
met medical chair legs madam chair yes
just my apologies for being late i'm
having trouble with my
netgear wi-fi and the only way i knew
how to fix it is go dig out my old one
and reconnect it
and that's still not working so well so
just well i i tell you what i'm pretty
amazed that you knew how
where the old equipment was because if i
tried to find all the equipment in my
house
i would still be searching now i'm
impressed
the time being one o'clock we are back
from
our lunch recess and i'd like to ask lba
to put up onto the shared screen
mm-hmm
thank you okay this is
house bill 532 which passed at our last
section
on the consent calendar and the chairman
and vice chairman of the policy
committee
have requested that this be put into hb2
uh tonight would move amendment two one
two zero two one dash o nine one nine h
emerick moves adoption of 202109198
i don't see any hands up so on the
motion of ought to pass
if the clerk could call the roll on
amendment 2021-09198
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
the clerk fought yes representative
griffin represented
yes representative hatch yes
representative uh waltz
i don't think she's on okay six nothing
madam chairman
the motion passes six to nothing
the next amendment i have mike if you
guys can bring up 20210914h
this is house bill 63
it allows a business
to ask to have a record sealed that
resulted from the pandemic
and authorizes the governor
to draw a warrant for up to 10 000 to
refund
fines assessed during the pandemic to
businesses
represent moves ought to pass represent
see no discussion if you're in favor of
the motion
about to pass on 202109 14h when your
name is called please say yes if not
please say no madam chairman yes vice
chairman yes
the clerk vote yes representative
griffin yes representative leachman
no okay representative hatch
no representative walsh no
to put house bill 544
as you guys see i inherited a lot of
amendments when i didn't think we were
going to have any
so this is hp 544
i inherited amendments from everybody
representative moves out to pass yes
represent griffin seconds
[Music]
yes
i don't know as i said i was handed a
bunch of amendments and this is house
bill 544. oh five four
four because i i didn't recognize it so
i just
i've been reading bills so things come
and go and i can't remember what i've
voted on what i haven't i now see matt
brought me
the american rescue plan act to read so
i did the recently passed biden coveted
bill on top of that i guess i'm going to
have something else to read all right on
the motion of ought to pass
on amendment 2021-0925-h with the clerk
please call the roll
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative sorry leishman
good grief every time madam chair i see
all these
words of flashpoint words
i'm going to vote no matter i'm chair
it's okay representative hatch
as am i no thank you okay representative
walls
[Music]
mary beth it must be muted no the ion
mutant no
544 is an awful bill it does not belong
here okay four to three
okay motion passes four to three
i have another handful of strange
amendments
mike i'm bringing up the corrections
hb1 adjustment for the doc
class lines for the move to rental
property
i did get an email on this so i had a
little background
doc commissioner helen hanks emailed me
apparently the building
that some of the staff is in the
probation and parole district office
is being sold this is across from the
courthouse
in newport and so they had to
move and this is the
funding required to give them
new rental offices she emailed me on
friday so this has just come up
and i mr hoffman i think you told me you
double checked with charlie arlene house
and d.a.s
and everything is correct on this
amendment
yeah you had corresponds nancy did okay
nancy yes ma'am um i corresponded with
charlie arlinghaus this morning
and while it is true the amen the um
amendment takes care of doc
administrative services
um is not ready to make any changes at
this time because the building is in
flux
so um there's no corresponding change
that they are requesting to their class
lines at this time yeah they'll have to
do that when they get to the senate but
we'll take care of the doc piece
so representative griffin moves ought to
pass
for representative emmerich seconds
[Music]
conversation if you're in favor of the
ought to pass when your name is called
please say yes if you're opposed please
say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes representative griffin
yes
representative leachman yes
representative hatch yes
representative walls yes seven or
nothing unanimous
motion passes seven to nothing
okay the next lovely thing
this is the case of no good deed goes
unpunished
your name on this amount of chair yeah
no good d
goes unpunished um so we had
in das administratively attached
to das the law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission
and i previously
had an amendment to push the start date
until the last three months of the year
which we did not pass unanimously by the
way
then it turned out after that was done
so that's why i said no good deed goes
unpunished
i left three months in there because it
would be easy for the senate when they
had more money
to fully fund it well then it turns out
it was budgeted incorrectly and there's
a study committee that has not
made its final recommendation so
when that came about we were asked
to remove the last three months
division two is going to put a section
in hb2
to allow some funding should that study
committee finish
but we don't know what it will look like
where it will be
so we need to vote to
remove the rest of the funding
as i said no good deed goes unpunished i
could have unfunded it but i wanted it
to be easy to put it back so
represent moves to accept
the hb1 amendment to remove the rest of
funding representative griffin seconds
represent walls your hand is up it is
i'm just trying to understand this i'm
sorry i did not fully follow your
explanation
so this was the leah commission and
there was funding for it and this is to
unfund the end of it am i hearing you
correctly
the lia commission was administratively
attached to das
and it was funded for the biennium okay
i removed all but three months of the
funding in a previous amendment
i think the day after that or two days
after that
i was notified that it was budgeted
incorrectly and all of it should have
should be removed
and a study was still going on and they
hadn't decided how the commission would
look
or where would be attached and so we
were advised
to remove the rest of the funding
and mr landrigan who supports
division two is working with that study
committee and with the chair of division
two
to get a section with appropriate
funding in into hb2
so that if um
the study ends and they need money they
will have money
in order to fund themselves so this is
removing what was what should never have
been budgeted
so madam chair am i correct that we're
basically removing it from the aas but
it's being put in the budget elsewhere
so that the leah community no that's
incorrect
that's right hb2 is going to have a div
section that says when the study is
finished
and if they go ahead with this there
will be funding
in order to establish it but it's not
yet determined
if it will go ahead what is this
this commission oh so if the commission
continues beyond
the issuance it hasn't started it may
not start
but if it does start from the study
committee's recommendation
there will be funding to start it up
[Music]
but the funding won't be here it's going
i don't know where the funding will go
finally it may come back into das
but division two is adding a little
section into hb2
that will allow the governor to fund
the study is not complete that
establishes this commission
this was premature but if the commission
thinks they need to keep going and the
governor doesn't then there's no funding
there's no commission yet well what has
it been that's been meaning what's the
leo
nothing the study group has been meeting
the commission's not
so they were a study group not a
commission and they might they may
evolve into a commission who knows
and if they do then the governor will
have discretion for money but the
members will not am i correct in
understanding this
i imagine if they do there will be a
bill that
comes forward and
since the funding has been set aside in
hb2 he will be able then
to have a fiscal note written to do that
but i have not been following this study
commission so i don't know where they
are
madam chair i'm sorry i don't have my
hand
up can i can i just ask
nancy the commission that that you're
referring to as lee act
was actually through executive order and
they did issue a final report
but they are still issuing reports and i
think there was an effort by the
governor's office to continue their work
in the form of a study to recommend
another entity
to take form at some point and in doing
so they put money in house bill 2
and they also created these lines in
house bill 1.
and division 2 has been working
diligently with the governor's office
and with the interested parties to
formulate a more
cohesive plan and in communication with
division two they just recommended that
this be taken out it was premature
and any funding would come through their
work within house bill 2
and that really was not something
division 1 needed to included
within das budget at this time
i hope that helps nancy basically got
double
funded correct yes and it's premature
was premature yes correct
nancy thank you for the explanation
that's much clearer i appreciate that
you're welcome
okay phantom chairman yes uh vice
chairman yes
the clerk vote yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman
representative hatch yes represent wals
and now that we've made our cuts
i have one more
amendment
to fund some additional positions in das
um i'm looking at the das priority
number 15 number 20. if nancy are you
and this restores six unfunded positions
um administrative supervisor or
part-time person
purchasing assistant a public works
project manager
an accounting technician an admin
assistant to
an internal auditor and you can see
the sources here not all of them are
general funds some of them are from
representative emerick moves to approve
representative griffin seconds
see no discussion could the clerk call
the roll phantom chair
yes there's also so let me just to be
clear i still don't see your hand up but
i guess you're talking
uh where does this money come from
that's all i'm trying to understand here
so the general fund and agency income
it's at the bottom two lines
yeah under source of funds it's fast to
read it microscopically so
okay so we're just basically expanding
the amount of money general fund money
we're spending at das
yes if you recall we cut out
the cyber insurance security insurance
that is now moved over to doit because
that should be
paid by every agency and every branch
and government
and then we found that the plant
maintenance
was double funded partly in general
funds and in fact all of it in general
funds when all of it should have been
other agency transfers
and some of this expense some of that
agency
income that they get there and we have
previously done those amendments i think
maybe even two weeks ago thank you madam
chair i just have a funny idea i want to
understand what i'm voting on before i
vote that's all so thank you
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes
the clerk of otis representative griffin
yes representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes represent
walls
yes okay unanimous seven nothing
represent walls i would say that we have
seven bright
minds around this table and we all want
to understand what we're voting for and
i kind of don't like your implication
that you're the only one who does so
please
remember that all of us are working very
diligently some of us remember things
from before and we
don't need as much explanation and some
of us need more explanation so more
explanation is always fine but we are
all
working on this this last amendment if i
could it comes from the governor's
budget page
525 is for the parole board
and this goes back to november last year
when i sat through the governor's budget
hearing in november
jennifer sargent the parole board
chairman wants to go into a more digital
environment for the parole board because
they get lots of paper
and she did not have accurate funding
and in november i asked her to go to the
doit
commissioner and get accurate funding
for the machines that she needed to get
in order to do this when she was here
she came she and doc commissioner helen
hanks came the very first day we started
budget deliberations
she still had not done that i told
reminded her that we were still waiting
for her to do that
she finally got this information to us
and what we've had to do is to revise
this budget somewhat
in order to include so that all five
members of the parole board
get the correct equipment and this has
run through
doit commissioner dennis goulet and he
has guaranteed
that it is correct at the same time she
came back and she said well
she'd forgotten some positions and she
needed this and she needed that
and it turns out one of the things
because she hadn't worked with the oit
that she didn't have was a thing called
a whap
a wireless access point which will be
installed
in their meeting room which will allow
their
laptops to connect to the server
and to wireless be able to wirelessly be
able to read the paperwork
so this includes the needed networking
equipment as well
because otherwise they were going to
have five ipads with no ability to get
on the network and now they're going to
have
five of those little dell computers like
commissioner goulet had when he was here
so this brings the appropriations
up and as you see at the bottom of this
it says amounts in addition to existing
appropriations in classes 37 and 38
that's because this includes hardware
and software networking hardware
computing hardware and software needed
to run the system she'd propose
so this gives her 100 percent funding
for her board
representative emerick moves out to pass
the clerk could call the roll on this
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk proceeds
representative griffin yes
representative lischmann representative
hatch
yes represent walls yes unanimous seven
nothing
okay nancy i think at this point with
those two things
we can finally approve the doit budget
yes ma'am i believe so i don't see any
other amendments unless mike wants to
no i don't see anything else the hardest
up here the hardest part is turning on
the mic so we have a similar problem
okay sharing screen is right up there
too
especially hunting up old netgear huh
bill exactly
okay an amen represent griffin
moves to approve the doit budget as
amended
mr clerk yes madam chairman yes
vice chairman yes the clerk vote yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman representative
hatch yes
representative walls yes seven nothing
unanimous madam chairman
okay my friends if you will turn to page
40 through 44
sections 71 through 91
what we have left are the ways and mean
sections that we were waiting for ways
and means
to give us the go ahead to approve or
amend
79 through 81 amends the interest and
dividend tax
as presented by the governor
ways and means has voted
i would like a motion to approve
sections
78 through 91 and hb2
representative griffin i'm sorry
representative eric mooz representative
i think you guys have probably all read
this a hundred times represent walls
i just want to understand what we're
doing to the israelis and dividends tax
here i'm not as fast
what's in hb2 the hb2 you've had
and i'm trying to come back and remember
this so i was looking for some guidance
madam chair
do you recall madam chair their vote was
it unanimous like the revenue numbers
or i don't recall norm saying anything
except
we were unanimous on this amendment we
approved going ahead on the tax cuts
so i didn't specifically ask him the
reason i
talked to him a little more about that
amendment was he had made a fairly
significant change and i was going to
try to have to come and explain some
ways and means in here
whereas this has been here for a while
and i'm sure if i may yes
can we ask perhaps either mike or nancy
to explain
exactly what we're doing here because
it's when you read it it's not
immediately apparent
at the bottom of the page section 78
this amends the interest and dividend
tax law
starts online at the end of 28
for all taxable periods ending before
december 31st
then line 30 the annual tax
upon income shall be levied at the rate
of 4
so it goes down a percentage
line 32 the annual tax rate upon income
shall be levied at the rate of 3
for all taxable periods ending on or
after
december 31st 24
line 34 the annual tax income
is levied at the rate of 2 percent line
the annual tax upon income shall be
levied at the rate of 1
for all taxable periods
so what this does is reduce the amount
of income tax
that many of us pay in the state of new
hampshire
over those periods by that percentage
and madam chair
on page 43 line
90 i'm sorry line 35 section 90
actually repeals the tax for the taxable
periods
beyond december 31st 2026
so it's a step down and a final phase
out and everything in between
is language in the statutes referring to
the ind
tax and just for the position of clarity
i did double check with the ethics
committee because i do pay this income
tax in new hampshire
however there are thousands of people
who pay it so i was told ethically i was
allowed to
vote on this because it did not just put
money in my pocket so i did double check
that before
we got here representative leishman
manager if i think you and i should both
pay this should i vote against the
amendment oh if you think we should keep
paying income tax then you vote against
these sections representative leishman
but if you're like me and tired of
paying income tax in new hampshire
[Music]
representative did you move adoption
representative griffin seconds that
motion
you may call the rule madam chairman yes
vice chairman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman
no representative hatch no
against my own interest representative
walsh
no against my interest because i pay a 2
and i'm still voting no
okay 43
okay if you could turn now to page 44
we have more um
tax cuts and these are sections 92
and 94 and these will
probably all be four to three as
republicans tend not to want to tax
people so we're always voting to lower
taxes
and this is the lowering of the rooms
and meals tax
there is no amendment on this so this
stays
this is exactly as presented in the
budget
this time representative emmerich
happily moves
madam chair would you just refresh my
memory as to which sections again please
you're looking at sections 92 and 94
starting on page 44 and ending on page
44.
the motion has been the to adopt if
you're in favor you'll please say yes
when your name is called if not you'll
say no
mr clerk yeah madam chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes uh the court votes
representative griffin
yes representative lynch leachman i know
representative hatch no and
if i may speak to it when we're done
thank you representative walls
four to three madam chairman okay the
next section
is my name madam chair just on that one
it's not that i
like taxing people or anything but um i
look at
value and i just believe
what we're doing here particularly with
the new to meals tax is
counterintuitive and will do more damage
than good
that's all thank you the next section is
section 95
through 97 and again we find these on
page
44. and shin
i'll surprise you madam chair i'll move
on to pass on this one
representative leishman moves out to
seconds
ready to call the role mr clerk
uh madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
uh the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes represent walls yes okay
unanimous seven nothing now okay we have
sections
98 and 99 98
it starts on line 37 of page 44 and
immediately
flips over to page 45
and again this is the business
enterprise tax and this reduces the rate
from 0.0675
representative emerick moves represent
griffin seconds
i don't see any discussion mr clerk
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leachman no
representative hatch no representative
walsh
nancy and mike i think we've concluded
our work
how about a sanity check um
i'm not sure if i have a brain left
that's okay uh just a quick question
yeah in your vote on sections 92 and 94
he did not include
section 93 which is an applicability
date
and uh wait a minute so
i didn't know if there was 92 to 94. yes
we did 92 93 and 94.
92-94 okay two okay
the only other que the only 95-9
so it's 96 got done just wanted to
double check with yeah nope thank you
the only other question that i had was
on page
94 and uh correct me again if i'm wrong
there were sections related to energy
but it has to do with the
um business and economic affairs taking
on the peace from
osi so they were sections
uh 9196 through
199 starting on page 94.
so assuming that you approve the doe as
you did earlier these would be
um i i just didn't have a record of how
and we did them so long ago i can't
remember well that could be my problem
too
uh well you know what we're just going
to be careful representative
emmerich will move to approve section
is it just one section nancy it's
through 199.
and and representative
griffin will second that and we'll just
vote that i can't remember
you can't remember that's a bad sign
so we'll be careful madam chairman this
is regard to what these are um
bea business of economic affairs
adopting and incorporating the office of
planning and development which came out
of osi
i know we approved his budget i can't
remember if we included these sections
at the same time so let's just vote them
separately
we're all shaking our heads here there's
seven five people this table always
going hmm
all right so on on the approval of
moving the office of plenty of
development to department of business
and economic affairs
if you're in favor say yes if you're
opposed say no
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes the clerk fought yes
representing griffin representative
lischmann representative hatch
yes excuse me representative walls
okay six and six to one madam chairman
okay
i had that marked off but i don't
remember
um anything else nancy because that's
all i got
despite our plethora of amendments today
ladies and gentlemen we have
handled all of them and thank you for
your hard work
i thought when we had lunch together
last week we would be
out of here in a in an hour hour and a
half this morning so it didn't work out
that way but it's okay we got to the end
thank you very much the division is
adjourned
peace